[Musique]
bonjour François Bayrou bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être ce matin j'aurais pu
dire que vous êtes également au
commissaire au Plan et ça va compter
parce qu'on se projette précisément sur
l'avenir hier donc présentation de ce
texte qui est un texte dit la première
ministre d'équilibre de justice de
progrès les syndicats ont immédiatement
répandus par l'organisation d'une
journée d'action alors à lieu jeudi la
semaine prochaine le 19 janvier le
gouvernement doit-il tenir bon face à
cette rue qui se prépare
lorsque vous présentez une réforme si
vous entrez dans le débat en considérant
que vous allez reculer c'est même pas la
peine de la présenter donc bien sûr le
gouvernement va défendre son projet
peut-être l'enrichir la première
ministre a dit que on n'était pas au
bout de du travail qui devait être fait
c'est pas la même chose d'ailleurs
et de l'enrichir comme vous dites bon
vous dites il faudra leur dire il faudra
le modifier alors un quel est le but du
texte le but du c'est en constatant que
les régimes de retraite
vont être en déficit aggravés dans les
années qui viennent de supprimer le
déficit pour les années qui viennent
d'effacer le déficit ça ne veut pas dire
que tous les déficits actuels sont
effacés mais on verra ça dans le temps
parce que cette question se posera
nécessairement mais on efface ou en tout
cas on supprime les causes les causes
des déficits à venir mais il y a mille
manières d'y parvenir mille manières d'y
parvenir
la première ministre a eu raison
d'insister sur le fait que il faut que
ce soit une réforme juste il faut
qu'elle soit perçue comme juste il faut
que tous les citoyens tous les Français
se disent bon on voit bien que c'est
nécessaire
mais tout de même l'essentiel des
préoccupations a été prise en compte je
voudrais pas juste aujourd'hui c'est
très réforme elle doit encore
s'améliorer je pense qu'elle est
améliorable je pense que on va entrer
dans une discussion parlementaire qui va
être Ardure on en dira peut-être un mot
bien sûr on va entrer dans un dialogue
avec les Français
les réflexions les protestations vous
dites avec les Français pas avec les
syndicats c'est-à-dire que quand Laurent
bergerquin syndicat réformiste la CFDT
dit on va s'engager dans une puissante
mobilisation dans la durée le 19 janvier
c'est la première journée peut-être
faut-il lire attentivement ce que
Laurent Berger alors dites-nous ce que
vous avez entendu Laurent Berger a dit
il n'y a pas de doute je traduis en
français
et peut-être d'ailleurs je suis assez
près de son texte il y a des avancées et
des progrès
notamment sur la pénibilité et les
carrières longues il faut en tenir
compte il faut
accepter de le reconnaître mais sur les
mesures d'âge nous sommes contre il dit
non non et non et nous sommes contre les
le déplacement de l'âge sauf on voit pas
le gouvernement bouger sur l'âge est-ce
que vous pensez que le gouvernement peut
est-ce que vous souhaitez que le
gouvernement bouge sur l'âge non je
pense que le gouvernement ne peut pas
faire autrement que de défendre ce
principe qui est de voir plus de
français au travail
et notamment plus de Français de plus de
60 ans au travail parce que nous sommes
le pays en Europe et peut-être parmi
tous les pays développés nous sommes le
pays dans lequel
les plus de 60 ans sont le moins
nombreux au travail et ceci est une
donnée vraiment très importante on peut
réformer contre tous les syndicats Unis
y compris contre la CFDT c'est pas un
souci dans un pays vous prenez souvent
le dialogue de dire on va assumer d'être
contre tous les syndicats
contre tous les syndicats je crois qu'il
y a beaucoup de nuances parmi les
syndicats il y a pour l'instant un
combat qu'ils ont décidé de livrer sur
l'âge mais quand vous êtes dans un pays
où le système de retraite l'ensemble de
l'équilibre des retraites et si
profondément menacé
y compris pour les pensionnés ce qui
aujourd'hui touchent des retraites vous
entendez des voix qui disent faut
demander des efforts aux retraités ce
qui pour moi est une rupture d'un
contrat social très très important a été
baissé les pensions de retraite par
exemple voilà baisser les pensions de
retraite pour moi c'est inacceptable
écraser de cotisations les salariés pour
moi c'est inacceptible vous vous aviez
dit on pourrait augmenter les
cotisations patronales latronale
patronale arrêtons-nous une seconde
parce qu'il est très important je
précise pour noter les spectateurs qui
ont pas tout suivi cette proposition
vous l'avait fait depuis plusieurs
semaines ici même sur splato en décembre
on en avait parlé ensemble pas d'accord
non et dans des termes d'ailleurs qui
sont assez durs Gabriel attalomisent des
comptes publics dit clairement c'est non
ce serait une baisse des salaires ou des
emplois supprimés ils donnent même des
chiffres et ce matin encore dans la
presse dans l'opinion il y a une
responsable de renaissance qui est cité
et qui dit à propos du MoDem ils vont
essayer de faire entendre une autre voix
mais ce ne sera pas audible donc là
clairement c'est une manière de vous
dire non merci François Hero
le débat il existe dans le pays il
existe à l'intérieur de la majorité
et on peut avoir des débats c'est pas
interdit c'est même souhaitable donc
vous maintenez cette proposition je vais
je sais très bien que le gouvernement
n'est pas de cet avis et mon idée n'est
pas de gêner ou de mettre en difficulté
le gouvernement mon idée est de chercher
la solution pour que dans les semaines
où ce débat va se développer et
peut-être
cette
cette ce dialogue avec avec des Français
y compris avec des plus contestataires
d'entre eux on puisse regarder s'il y a
des marges de progrès alors
la situation est que beaucoup de
Français ont le sentiment qu'on demande
les efforts toujours eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire à ceux qui sont au travail
et pas du tout
à ceux qui à la tête des entreprises ou
dans les entreprises ou les entreprises
elles-mêmes donc c'est une question de
justice quand Elisabeth bandit est un
projet de justice vous dites il peut
l'être encore un peu plus je pense qu'on
peut progresser dans la définition de ce
texte d'ailleurs le gouvernement comme
vous avez vu a fait un pas dans la
direction que je souhaitais il y a un
petit basculement de cotisation qui vont
être transférées en faveur de la branche
qui finance les retraites et on va de se
fait faire un petit effort sur les
cotisations qui financent par exemple
les maladies du travail et les accidents
de travail bon c'est une petite astuce
mais ça fait pas contribuer davantage
les patrons vous vous disiez
contribution supplémentaire vous voyez
le l'expression que vous avez utilisé
même si elle est en raccourci est une
expression qui n'est pas juste ça j'ai
pas de contribuer les patrons il s'agit
de faire contribuer les entreprises qui
contribuent déjà pas mal et j'avais j'ai
chiffré cet effort à environ 07% de la
masse salariale alors que cette année la
masse salariale va augmenter en moyenne
de plus de 5 % mais ça veut dire
alourdir légèrement le coût du travail
ça veut dire oui
si vous voulez financer un système de
retraite pour qu'il soit à l'équilibre
au plus exactement pour qu'il ne
connaissent pas de déséquilibre
supplémentaire parce qu'aujourd'hui il
n'est pas à l'équilibre aujourd'hui les
régimes de retraite le système de
retraite est à l'équilibre parce que
l'État contribue pour au moins 30
milliards pour retrouver l'équilibre 30
milliards ça fait 30 000 millions
d'euros chaque année mais dès lors que
le gouvernement dit en augmentera pas
les impôts par les cotisations c'est
quoi la solution de compromis avec votre
proposition non mais d'abord je ne suis
pas dans un dans la recherche d'un
compromis avec le gouvernement
j'essaie de regarder comment les
Français vont trouver que le nouveau
système est juste
porter cette proposition non ils sont
dans un dialogue avec le gouvernement la
première ministre la d'hier elle a dit
ce texte n'est pas au bout de son
évolution on va pouvoir discuter avec
les groupes parlementaires et c'est ce
que nous allons faire et ils le font
très bien et ils sont très courageux
dans cette exercice je veux dire
seulement un sujet au moins qui me
paraît devrait être très bien précisé
c'est la pénibilité
le il y a des travaux qui sont des
travaux
usants pour les salariés et il faut que
tout le monde soit rassuré sur le fait
que cette usure j'évoque toujours la
situation des des aides-soignantes
je les connais bien dans un organisme
comme le
le CCAS l'aide sociale de Pau je vois
très bien ce que ça représente le centre
d'action sociale qui est dans chaque
commune et dans chaque commune de centre
communal d'action sociale et cette la
charge les charges que c'est femme c'est
souvent des femmes sont obligées de
lever c'est évidemment usant donc il
faut préparer les syndicats les
syndicats hier disent et Laurent Berger
le premier on veut pas d'une
individualisation c'est à dire que là le
dispositif que propose le gouvernement
c'est une visite médicale pour chacun
des pertes chacune des personnes
concernées alors même qu'on a du mal à
trouver des médecins c'est vrai que ça
crée de l'incompréhension est-ce que
vous vous dites c'est un bon dispositif
est-ce qu'il faut individualiser faire
une visite médicale lire
c'est pas une offense de dire on vérifie
le si l'organisme de chacun la situation
de santé de chacun des salariés mais il
est vrai qu'il y a des travaux pénibles
par exemple
des charges à soulever dans plusieurs
mon métier et je suis certain que le
gouvernement veut le prendre en compte
le gouver à discussion avec les
syndicale gouvernement n'a retenu 3 oui
c'est déjà un progrès
je disais un introduction français
en décembre vous nous disiez que vous
étiez favorable à des semaines de
discussion supplémentaires il y a eu
effectivement un report de la
présentation de la réforme est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que ce report a
servi à quelque chose parce que les
syndicats sont exactement à la même
position qu'au mois de décembre
peut-être la seule ouverture qu'on voit
c'est que ça permet de préparer un
accord avec les républicains pour le
coup c'est vrai que les républicains
peut-être en dialogue avec l'exécutif il
faut pas restreindre
l'effet de ces mois supplémentaires je
pense que cet effet a été très important
pour au moins deux sujets sur les trois
que j'évoquais à votre micro le premier
de ces sujets c'est qu'on a pu
progresser avec les organisations
syndicales sur les carrières longues sur
la pénibilité il y a eu un travail de
bonne foi qui a été conduit et je crois
que les responsables syndicaux le
reconnaissent on a fait des pas en avant
dans la précision de ce qui était
nécessaire deuxièmement très important
on a évité l'écueil que je trouvais
dangereux de faire une réforme
brutalement à l'emporte-pièce par
amendement qui auraient été interprétés
comme un passage en force enfin on a
quand même un projet de loi de la
sécurité là oui mais c'est un projet
c'est pas un amendement donc c'est
convenable comme ce que vous avez vu
aussi les critiques sur la procédure
parlementaire il y a ceux qui disent on
va avoir 20 heures en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale ça valait à toute
allure
un jour vous avez raison 20 jours
c'est quand même très rapide parce que
ça veut dire qu'il y a certains
amendements qui vont pas pouvoir être
examinés surtout que si une partie de
l'opposition a annoncé qu'ils allaient
en déposer 75000
et que il faut 5 minutes par amendement
au moins alors vous voyez que c'est fait
pour empêcher toute discussion et je
trouve que ça n'est pas une bonne
démarche ça veut dire que le
gouvernement pense aura raison de passer
par 49-3 s'il le faut pour accélérer les
débats aussi je suis pas sûr que il
passera par le 49 3 qu'est-ce qui vous
fait dire ça d'autre solution il y a
d'autres articles dans la Constitution
qui permettent d'accélérer pour un texte
de cet ordre l'examen et de le dans les
conditions d'examen parlementaires et
donc de ce point de vue là ça c'est la
deuxième chose on a évité
l'impression d'un d'un coup de bambou
sur la tête qui aurait été de donner par
le dépôt subreptice ou
inattendu donne un amendement et c'est
une chose très importante il y a une
chose que j'attendais et on n'a pas
réussi à l'obtenir c'est une démarche
pédagogique pour que l'opinion soit
informée chacun des citoyens précisément
de la situation des systèmes de retraite
donc vous demandez au gouvernement de le
faire davantage comme vous savez nous
avons fait une analyse au plan qui a
examiné la situation
financière budgétaire de notre système
de retraite et qui a fait apparaître les
déficits actuels
en sachant très bien que tout
aggravation irait évidemment dans un
mauvais sens est-ce que vous êtes
convaincu que c'est uniquement une
question de pédagogie parce qu'il y a
des français d'après les enquêtes
d'opinion les Français sont
majoritairement opposés à la réforme
peut-être qu'en effet certains sont pas
informés mais il y en a aussi qui sont
informés et qui sont en désaccord qui ne
veulent pas travailler plus longtemps
pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris mais
parce que ce n'est pas leur souhait
alors
est-ce qu'on peut changer
c'est ce que je crois l'organisation des
carrières professionnel pourquoi est-ce
que beaucoup de Français
majoritaires souvent des sondages mais
j'attends de voir la réalité humaine
vous avez raison ce sont des sondages
beaucoup de Français
enfin de carrière ont un sentiment de
très grand de lassitude
on fait le même métier depuis des années
et des années il n'y a pas d'évolution
il y a pas de responsabilité
supplémentaire et quand il y a évolution
et responsabilité supplémentaires la
plupart du temps ils choisissent de
prolonger leur carrière ils choisissent
de rester quelques années de plus pour
améliorer leur situation financière pour
améliorer leur futur pension de retraite
ou parce que simplement on a de jeunes
enfants et tout ça fait évidemment de
autant de raisons pour
allongé et là pour améliorer ça sur quoi
est-ce qu'il doit agir pour améliorer ça
ben je pense que non seulement il doit
le gouvernement doit agir mais les
entreprises doivent agir et les
syndicats doivent agir c'est un appel
que vous lancez aux entreprises de
responsabilité c'est l'organisation du
travail qui fait que la France est le
pays de tous les pays en Europe
ou on parle plutôt à la retraite et si
c'était un système financièrement
équilibré ça pourrait aller mais les
déséquilibres de ce système menacent la
vie de
beaucoup de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui à
la route vous entendez France Bayrou à
votre place hier il y avait Alexis
Corbière la France insoumise vous étiez
tout à l'heure les volonté d'obstruction
parlementaire faut dire ce qui est quand
on parle de 75000 amendements mais il
conteste au-delà de l'usage de 49,3 les
oppositions le fait que le Parlement
aujourd'hui ne soit pas à l'image du
pays des syndicats je disais tout à
l'heure 8 syndicats opposés des Français
majoritairement opposés vous qui êtes
toujours attaché bien et au respect de
la démocratie est-ce que la démocratie
fonctionne bien lorsque on a une
majorité qui se dessine au Parlement
mais qu'elle ne reflète ni la vie des
syndicats ni la vie du pays à ce stade
est-ce que la démocratie est de bonne
qualité en France pas assez très loin
d'être un bon seuil pourquoi parce qu'en
France ça fonctionne toujours de la même
manière il n'y a de réformes que dans
des crises
chaque fois qu'il y a une réforme c'est
une crise je ferai remarquer au
demeurant que les gouvernements suivants
ne reviennent jamais sur la réforme
telle qu'elle a été adoptée mais cette
conflictualité cette organisation
systématique de conflits sur toutes les
décisions à prendre est une mauvaise
chose et ça empêche la France d'être ce
qu'elle devrait être un exemple
démocratique pourquoi parce qu'on
considère en France que au fond les
citoyens
ils n'ont qu'un rôle c'est
attendre la décision du sommet et puis
soit l'accepter soit si opposé et c'est
pas comme ça que pour moi la démocratie
devrait être la démocratie devrait être
ce que j'appelle démocratie de
co-responsabilité c'est-à-dire qu'on
devrait considérer les citoyens ce qui
nous écoutent les femmes les hommes qui
sont dans la vraie vie comme des
partenaires des co-décidaires et on
devrait notamment pour leur donner tous
les éléments pour que se forme leur
opinion mais d'autant qu'aujourd'hui
il y a aussi des gens aujourd'hui qui
quand ils entendent le gouvernement le
président de la République dire j'ai été
élu sur ce projet disent mais il se
moque de nous on est allé voter au
deuxième tour pour faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen si c'est ça la prochaine
fois on se déplacera pas on n'ira pas
faire barrage comme ça on nous renverra
pas le programme dans la figure vous
avez raison beaucoup de gens le disent
ou le pense ou un certain nombre le
disent ou le pense et c'est vrai qu'une
élection ne règle pas la suite du
quinquennat mais c'est vrai aussi que
c'est le projet que le Président de la
République avait mis en avant vous vous
souvenez que il a une distance 65 ans le
coeur
voyage entre le premier et le deuxième
tour dans le Nord il a dit 704 donc vous
voyez bien que c'était présent dans son
esprit mais pourquoi parce que vous
pouvez pas laisser la situation comme ça
le le la seule certitude qui était celle
du président de la République qui est
celle du gouvernement et qui est c'est
que la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes n'est pas tenable le le
ce n'est pas les actifs qui peut les
retraites contrairement à ce que devrait
être génial
c'est le budget de l'État dont les
impôts des Français mais ça va tenir
combien de temps François c'est très
fort elle va nous permettre d'être
tranquille pour combien d'années parce
que c'est là je crois cinquième réforme
depuis le début des années 90 on remet
régulièrement le sujet sur la table il
faut y revenir là il y a et on peut s'en
féliciter pour ceux qui seront concernés
beaucoup de concessions qui ont été
faites des gestes sociaux mais qui vont
aussi coûter de l'argent est-ce que dans
quelques années il faudra reprendre le
travail pour travailler vous avez raison
de poser la question comme ça c'est
c'est absolument justifier quand on
regarde la réalité des des chiffres je
vous disais au moins 30 milliards
parents 30 milliards d'euros 30 000
millions d'euros par an tous les ans il
faudra y revenir je pense que la
réflexion qui doit être conduite est une
réflexion de long terme sur progressive
de retour à un authentique équilibre
pour l'instant ce que le gouvernement
fait c'est supprimer ou en tout cas
effacer les déficits à venir faudra se
demander combien de temps dans sa vie on
passe à travailler pour le dire
différemment oui mais il y a une chose
que je voudrais dire avec vous il y a un
sujet qu'il faudra aborder je ne sais
pas si ce sera dans la période de cette
réforme mais c'est la gouvernance des
systèmes de retraite qui décident on a
comme vous savez à l'heure actuelle 42
régimes de retraite si on croit que
c'est viable 42 régimes de retraite moi
je crois qu'on pourrait simplifier tout
ça
la question c'est
comment les décisions sont prises et par
qui pour faire évoluer les régimes et
vous souhaitez que ce soit parti il y a
un très bon exemple c'est les régimes de
retraite du privé qui s'appelle agircoz
où là sont les partenaires sociaux qui
décident ce sont les partenaires et ils
ont fait toutes les adaptations
nécessaires